I want to talk about a hidden source of
heart attacks that you may have never
even considered before but I think it's
very very common uh not talked about
enough and since heart disease is the
number one killer on planet Earth it
might be a good idea for you to know
more about this topic the unique thing
about the heart muscle is that the heart
muscle is different than the skeletal
muscles it never has a chance to fully
relax and recover it's constantly
beating 24 7 whereas your other muscles
can have a chance to relax they don't
have to constantly work but that heart
has to keep working and when someone
dies from a heart attack
it's actually the heart and muscle
itself that stops Contracting and
relaxing it tends to quiver and then you
basically die and so people don't really
die because of of the artery itself it's
the heart muscle okay now it's true that
you can have a blocked artery that stops
the blood flow to the heart muscle but
you die from the heart muscle
malfunctioning because of a lack of
oxygen it's called hypoxia or ischemia
which is a lack of blood flows and as
you know anytime you have a lack of
oxygen to a muscle it cramps okay it
stops Contracting and relaxing for
muscle to work it needs a lot of oxygen
unless you're doing some short Sprints
this high intensity type of exercise
where you operate with a different
system where you don't need oxygen but
that's very short-lived and you can only
go so far before you hit a wall now when
someone gets heart attack sometimes I do
this test to measure this enzyme la
rotate dehydrogenase I did a video on
this which is an enzyme involving
lactate which I'll get into in a minute
but when this enzyme is in higher
amounts it could mean that you just had
a heart attack within 24 to 72 hours but
it can also mean other things too like
B12 Anemia as in pernicious anemia it
could mean that you have AIDS the kidney
the liver pancreatitis it could even
indicate that you have cancer because
there's destruction of the tissues and
with this destruction comes hypoxia so
hypoxia can also Elevate this as well
what's interesting about this topic is
I'm going to work backwards and show you
how someone could actually get to this
situation where they have too much
lactic acid in their body lactic acid is
related to lactate too much lactate
gives you lactic acid and now the pH it
goes down more acidic and then you run
out of air really quick so where does
lactate come from well it comes from
this uh kind of this compound called
pyruvate and pyruvate is kind of a
middleman in this chain reaction and
that comes from glucose so when you burn
glucose fuel it turns into pyruvate and
then lactate and then eventually lactic
acid now another name for glucose is
sugar right and you probably already
know that sugar is not good for the
heart and you may know that when you
have elevated glucose as in a diabetic
that glucose can really raise up your
triglycerides because they convert to
fat and you might also know that if
you're on a high sugar diet you're going
to have high levels of LDL cholesterol
but what you might not know is there's
something else that releases a lot of
glucose that has nothing to do with your
diet okay nothing to do with what you
ate and that is called
adrenaline
maybe you were going to say cortisol and
you're correct on that but adrenaline is
also another hormone-like communication
potent neurotransmitter that raises your
glucose and adrenaline comes from stress
and the more chronically stressed you
are the more adrenaline you're going to
have the more glucose that your body is
going to
make or release which is going to turn
into the paruvate the lactate and the
lactic acid and it's going to create
hypoxia there's some fascinating
research and I'll put it the link Down
Below on this topic on the stress
connection to heart attacks because
stress creates hypoxia in a big way
through adrenaline and cortisol too so
even when someone is has low blood
sugars adrenaline kicks in there and
mobilizes a lot of the glucose in the
body to raise the blood sugar and
cortisol does the same thing but
adrenaline is designed for quick energy
to if you're chased by a tiger you have
to generate quick energy and so the body
is going to release glucose but what
happens when you're under constant
stress over a period of time you're
basically it's like the same thing as
eating a lot of sugar and even though
adrenaline creates a vasodilation to the
coronary artery it creates
vasoconstriction of the other blood
vessels around the body to the point
where there's no more vasodilation
there's this vasoconstriction so this
could also explain if someone
I don't know over exercises and they're
not a good shape and then they dropped
out of heart attack because of this
adrenaline situation it also explains
the higher risk of getting heart attacks
from a severe shock to the system of a
stress loss of a loved one loss of a
friend
loss of money loss of job loneliness
divorce illness injury being in the
situation where you're constantly
fighting with someone or you're being
affected by them or you have a you know
chronic anxiety anger or depression or
just being in a fear State can all raise
your level of adrenaline to the point
where you're feeding way too much sugar
to the body and especially the heart
muscle and you're generating a lot of
lactate which is turning into lactic
acid creating a bad situation for the
heart muscle in fact very specifically
when you have too much lactic acid in
the heart and muscle you start to
develop arrhythmias like atrial fib that
doesn't always necessarily just come
from an electrolyte imbalance it can
come from this hypoxia because there's
damage going on into the heart muscle
high blood pressure is another effect of
this as well Harding of the art arteries
is another effect of this and eventually
necrosis which is like your heart
muscles start breaking down and dying
because you don't have enough oxygen for
arrhythmias especially atrial fib after
heart attack one of the medications they
use is digitalis and digitalis does
increase more blood flow
but it also is a potent inhibitor of
this lactic acid which is very
interesting and is probably the reason
why it actually does keep people alive
the other interesting thing about
adrenaline is that when you're under
chronic stress it's going to raise
especially your LDL cholesterol which is
the small dense particle size LDL as
well as increasing your triglycerides
now normally those two would be
increased when you're eating sugar you
wouldn't think they'd be elevated with
stress
adrenaline but yes adrenaline does do
that so the real problem with a lot of
people is they're under this sympathetic
nervous system dominance they don't have
enough of the opposing parasympathetic
which is the calming which is
responsible for rest and digestion right
the sympathetic nervous system is all
about fight or flight mode fight meaning
more like the emotion of anger or flight
meaning the emotion of fear where you're
running away from something I'm bringing
up this point because I want you to be
very aware of
I think a very common root cause of
heart problems that you can do something
about okay once you identify this
mechanism now there are other things
that also increase lactate directly that
then will increase lactic acid and a
hypoxia that you should be aware of and
one is smoking and vaping when people
Vape if you ever look at the ingredients
one of the ingredients is propylene
glycol that's antifreeze okay propylene
glycol increases lactate especially when
it's heated in a vapor State and I think
they use it for the flavoring but I'm
not sure exactly why they use it but if
you vape I would make sure that it
doesn't have that ingredient but the
other problem with vaping is that it has
nicotine which also increases adrenaline
and can cause this whole Chain Reaction
just from that same thing with smoking I
mean when you think about smoking
there's no fat or cholesterol in smoking
in a cigarette is there no there's not
then why is it that smokers have
elevated cholesterol and triglycerides
because smoking increases adrenaline
which then increases glucose which then
increases cholesterol and triglycerides
smoking actually does not relieve stress
it causes more stress and increasing
your chance for heart attacks because of
this hypoxia smoking in general will
increase your chance of a heart attack
by 5 times vaping will increase your
chance of getting a heart attack by two
times now another thing that can create
this hypoxia is Tylenol poisoning
another one would be inflammation
another would be diabetes and we've
already talked about sugar the number
one type of sugar that will cause high
levels of lactic acid and lactic
acidosis in this hypoxia
is fructose you know that stuff that we
drink in sodas and these fruit juices
that we shouldn't be drinking it's the
fructose another thing that can cause
hypoxia is cyanide poisoning alcohol is
another one that can increase lactic
acidosis and hypoxia and the medication
meant for men it has a black label which
means that it has a very severe side
effect called lactic acidosis and so
metformin can cause this state as well
and this is why the next thing I'm going
to say makes a lot of sense
a B1 deficiency and a B12 deficiency can
increase lactate lactic acidosis and
hypoxia and that's one of the things
that metformin does is it creates a B1
and B12 deficiency anything that creates
a B1 B12 deficiency like sugar stress
and just a lot of carbohydrates can
create this hypoxia
this is probably why when people are
under stress and they take B1 or
sometimes B12 they just
they can breathe better they have more
oxygen they feel less stressed so here's
what I recommend you do number one you
have to reduce the triggers of your
stress no matter you know whatever you
can do for that especially if it's
chronic okay but then number two you
have to do things to kind of flush out
the stress on a daily basis and this
would be long walks walking in nature on
a regular basis it flushes out
adrenaline it flushes out cortisol
with also intermittent higher intense
exercise with lots of rest number three
avoiding sugar okay well now you know
why because you don't want that to turn
into
lactic acid and hypoxia that's called
the ketogenic diet in taking B1 on a
regular basis can greatly help keep
lactic acid at Bay and since we're on
the topic of the heart muscle one of the
most important
nutrients to increase the level of
oxygen in the heart muscle itself is
called tocatrinols it's a type of
vitamin E that I recommend so now that
you're aware of the stress factor
adrenaline
let's talk about
um the calcium buildup in the arteries
that's a a little bit different topic
but related I put that up right here